salut c'est Tracy fishko je vais à l'université
dans la ville et ma mère a dit que je devrais
t'appeler ma mère épouse ton père
Times Square est tellement fou je ne connais
personne qui a vécu ici vraiment vôtre j'ai pris
le bus de Jersey je pensais  c'était
l'endroit cool où vivre c'est time square
c'est tellement élégant je sais que je suis
décorateur d'intérieur indépendant ici l'hôtel Bowery
oh mon dieu ouais eh bien si vous vous promenez dans un
pâté de maisons au sud il y a un centre d'épilation au laser
qui est très branché j'ai fait l'attente
chambre
elle a vécu exactement comme doit vivre une jeune femme
qui veut bien passer sa
jeunesse elle a tout fait et rien tu
ne sais pas ce que tu vends personne
ne saura l'acheter ou tu
vends tant de choses étant autour d'elle
C'était comme être à New York Je suis un
autodidacte savez-vous ce que cela signifie
oui ce mot est l'une des choses que j'ai
appris moi-même les gens prennent toujours
mes idées mon ex-amie et ennemie
mamie-claire a volé mes idées et  ma
fiancée et puis elle a littéralement volé  mon
chat tu dois chercher cet
esprit mamie-claire dit que tu as
des affaires inachevées avec cette femme
tu devras écouter l'esprit
jeune a raison pas si jeune 10 10 à 12
ans de moins étaient des contemporains d'accord
qu'est-ce que tu fais ici sont ceux-ci  les gens
ce sont mes amis la dernière fois que je vous ai vu
vous vous cachiez dans les buissons et
puis vous avez commencé à crier de manière incohérente sur
moi et mon mari sur la façon dont nous
réalisons tous et la fois avant
que vous vomissiez à mon mariage
sont ceux mes chats  il n'y a pas de tromperie
quand tu as 18 ans tu devrais tous te
toucher tout le temps
tu es drôle parce que tu ne sais pas que tu es
drôle je sais que je suis drôle il n'y a rien que je
ne sais pas sur moi c'est pourquoi je
Je ne peux pas faire de thérapie, bien sûr, je
faisais semblant de rembobiner comme
[Musique]